Jennifer Lopez kicks off her birthday  week with boyfriend Alex Rodriguez in  Miami he's such a supportive person and  he's so lovely  [Music]  JLo turned 48 on Monday July 24th and to  celebrate another year of being flawless  Jenny enjoyed a pre bday dinner with  a-rod Sunday night at prime 112  restaurants the singer looked like a  vision in white steppin out in a stylish  figure fitting bodysuit and matching  wide slacks while her dapper beau wore a  navy blazer collared button-down and  jeans  Jennifer's were the most brilliant  business mind I've ever met she's the  hardest working lady  a-rod's hard-working girlfriend wasn't  the only one celebrating turning another  year older  [Music]  the former MLB pro turns 42 on July 27th  so the two lovebirds had a joint party  with their closest friends and family  the superstar couple posted this pic  from their evening captioned happy  birthday to us  hashtag Leo's I feel like a teenager  again  [Music]